the demi-god children and stepchildren
of queen america are said to be the most
powerful beings in the lands between all
of them are unique in their appearances
fighting styles abilities factions
aspirations and beliefs when we meet
morgot outside the doors of the erd tree
we start to understand that all of the
demigods besides morgot have ultimately
left their family lineage and have
stopped following the greater will in
search of their own beliefs but queen
america had her own doubts of the
greater will and devised a plan to test
their power before america shattered the
elden ring she gave her children
powerful great runes and had one hope
for all of them which is told to us by
melina just outside the capital city in
america's own words
hear me
demigods
my children beloved
make of thyselves
that which he desire
be it a lord
be it a god
but should he fail to become ought at
all
you will be forsaken
amounting only to
sacrifices if you want my full detailed
theory on queen america's plan to test
the greater will you can watch my video
called queen america's perfect plan
today i want to make you all feel a
little worse about yourselves not
because i want to but because once i
started to research and understand the
history of all of the demigod children i
realized that when we fight them these
gods are likely at their weakest state
there was likely a time before we were
called back to the world as a tarnished
that these demigods were insanely more
powerful than when we fight them we are
called back by the guidance of grace in
order to restore the elden ring only
after the great war between all of the
demigod siblings known as the shattering
when we take our first steps into
limgrave we can only see the aftermath
of this war castles bridges towers
everything is in ruin following several
different wars there's the war of the
shattering the war between the carrion
royals and the academy scholars the
battle between the misbegotten and the
knights of limgrave the red main
soldiers and the spread of the scarlet
rot the albanorics fighting to keep
their race alive and finding hopeful
salvation at the haleg tree and many
other examples needless to say the world
we play the game in is not how it's
always been in many ways i wish we could
see the lands between before all of this
discourse and i hope that we see that
world potentially in future dlcs they've
hinted at some time travel aspects of
the game when we entered the dragonlord
fight but for now i'd like to go over
and speculate on the true power these
demigods likely held at one point and if
they've grown stronger or weaker since
the
shattering before we get started i'd
like to point out a couple things first
off these videos are usually pure
speculation and based on theories so if
you have your own theory on this topic
let me know down in the comments i'd
also like to remind you to subscribe to
the channel but only if you enjoy the
content you're watching i started a
patreon page where you can give some
extra support if you want to there's
only one tier that you can join where
you'll receive early access to all
videos with no ads discounts on
exclusive eldon ring merchandise that
i'm currently working on with my sister
a special tarnish warrior discord role
and shout outs in every video i make so
a special thank you to pascal john and
arthea with all of that said let's get
into the video
i'd like to first talk about godwin the
golden because there isn't much known
about the likely firstborn of queen
america in godfrey we know where he is
now a victim of the knight of black
knives a plot devised by ronnie the
witch to shed her imperial flesh in
order to break free from the influence
of the greater will both ronnie and
godwin were stabbed with these knives
marked with the fragment of the rune of
death ronnie's body was killed in this
process but freed her spirit from this
body to do with as she wishes however
godwin's spirit was killed in this
ritual process leaving only a deformed
husk of a body that has been twisted and
mangled with no spirit to guide it
before the death of godwin's spirit
godwin was a part of the golden lineage
being son to godfrey the first elden
lord it's likely that godric the grafted
was also a descendant of godfrey's
golden lineage and could be the son of
godwin himself during the early days of
queen america's reign the urgery was
attacked by ancient dragons who ruled
over the lands between long before the
erd tree i find it fitting that godric
again likely son of godwin had such an
interest in these dragons since his
father battled against them and
eventually befriended one of these
powerful dragons known as fortasax after
we defeat fortisacks we receive the
remembrance of the lich dragon which
reads after godwin the golden became the
prince of death the ancient dragon
fought long and hard against the death
within its companion alas victory was
never achieved and its only reward was
corruption so even after battling
against and defeating the ancient
dragons godwin and fortisacks cultivated
a powerful relationship so much so that
fortisacks would attempt to battle
against the death within godwin but
would ultimately lose that battle we can
only imagine the influence and power
godwin held to be able to defeat the
dragons because all we see of godwin now
is this it's sort of sad based on the
opening cinematic godwin likely didn't
see his death coming dying to the black
knight assassins cloaked in invisible
veils so here he is a husk of his former
self his body used to complete ronnie's
ritual before becoming the prince of
death and then used after by fia the
deathbed companion i will soon lay with
godwin
and it will surely stir within me
the new life of the golden prince
and first dead of the demigods
as the rune of those who live in death
now i don't know about you guys but i
found godric the grafted to be the
easiest demigod to defeat while he
portrays himself as a powerful lord he's
ultimately a pushover not only to us but
the rest of the demigods as well we can
learn from kenneth height that godric at
one point insulted melania apparently
regarding her clothing fled the capital
city hid from radon and was eventually
put in his place by melania honestly god
drake's nothing more than a jumped up
country bumpkin
lord
don't make me laugh
first he hid himself amongst the women
folk to flee the capital then hid from
radon in that castle
then he insulted melania lost to her in
battle only to lick her boots rather
than die like a man
has he no shame the big girl's blouse
and to think he's the blood of godfrey
last of the golden lineage
though you almost wouldn't know it to
look at him
yeah i almost feel sorry for the chap
the more i think of it i think this
tells us most of what we need to know
about godric before we fight him he's
pathetic constantly seeking power by any
means necessary using the grafting
process to attach limbs to his own body
in order to grow stronger he isn't
likable when we fight him and it doesn't
look like he was much like beforehand
either in my opinion godric was likely
trying to live up to his golden lineage
that being godfrey the first elden lord
and renowned successful warrior for the
greater will and as we talked about
godwin who defeated the ancient dragons
morgot likely only put his summoning
location at stormville castle so we
couldn't get godric's great rune as
easily as i find the battle on the
bridge with margaret much more difficult
than godric himself he even has the best
great rune that we can collect in elden
ring giving us an increase in all of our
attributes which given the easier
difficulty of this boss is surprising i
believe godric was likely spoiled and
maybe mostly ignored by his family as no
one really thought of him as much to
think about so he made himself louder
verbally and physically as when he goes
into his second phase he references his
forefathers to look at what he has now
become forefathers one on all
fitness
let's move on to the omen twins morgot
in moog these two are likely the only
demigods who did not become somewhat
weaker in the time before the shattering
and when we fight them which is sort of
fitting since both had the hardest
upbringing of all of their siblings
they're omens born of many grotesque
horns growing out of their body any
babies born in omen would have their
horns cut off and they would be banished
to the sewers below the capital city for
all of eternity most of the time when
these horns are removed it would lead to
death however if an omen was born of
royalty their horns would not be removed
but they would still be banished to the
sewers before the shattering these twins
likely grew up in these disgusting
sewers both of them which were shackled
forced to stay in the sewers even if
they wished to leave but it looks like
both of them grew strong enough to break
free from these shackles morgot seemed
to plan on how he could be of value to
his family outside the sewers even as an
omen taking on the alias as margaret he
could leave the sewers under cover and
created the knight's cavalry these
knights would travel across the lands
between and would deliver death to great
warriors knights and champions moore got
wished to serve the greater will and
protect the capital city and it's clear
that he was a powerful warrior during
the shattering war even seemingly
beating back a smaller version of radon
in order to protect his city this is all
he wanted to do protect his home after
the shattering all of his siblings had
abandoned the greater will leaving only
him to be the one true king of leiandel
a place that as soon as he was born
shunned him for something he could not
control
willful traitors
oh
moog went a different route than his
twin brother almost a polar opposite of
morgot moog decided to instead embrace
his differences and seeks to work not
for the greater will but another outer
god known as the formless mother and
create his own dynasty one of moog's
attacks is an incantation known as blood
boon the item description reads thrust
arm into the body of the formless mother
then scatter the blood flame to set the
area ablaze the mother of truth craves
wounds when moog stood before her deep
underground his accursed blood erupted
with fire and besotted with the
defilement that he was born into so moog
became infatuated with his omen roots
and that of the mother of truth
otherwise known as the formless mother
when i hear the word formless i think of
liquid so it would make sense that this
liquid could be that of blood making
this outer god the mother of blood
obviously moak has gone down this
blood-ridden path in order to form his
own dynasty we can hear more from gideon
on what goes on at the mogwan palace
oh so that's where the so-called lord of
blood was hiding himself eh
a fitting little squat for that deluded
maniac to bleed about the revival of his
precious dynasty
while he turns our fellow tarnished into
bloody fingers
let him stay there
that way
his delusions will remain as they are
distant and unattainable this tells us
that moog is trying to revive his
dynasty meaning that he's attempted this
before it seems based on what gideon
says moog's army are past tarnished that
he's trying to turn into his own fingers
no idea how this works but it seems like
this process continues to just not go
well we also all know that moog took
mykola from the haley tree it's possible
moog needs mikala in order to complete
his dynasty but at this point we don't
know how or why that could be possible
maybe mikola has the ability to turn
mogu's army into the powerful fingers
that he needs or mikala has a lord moog
in order to stop him from reaching the
above ground as mikala possesses the
wisdom the allure of a god he is the
most fearsome empyrean of all as it says
in the description of melania's armor
set so we'll all have to wait for more
information to surface in future dlc
now we're going to talk about the
demigod children of ratagan and ranala
it's believed that reichard was the
firstborn of this relationship but not
much is known about reichard before the
shattering it's theorized however that
reichard conspired with his sister
ronnie in order to help destroy her
connection to the greater will it's not
known exactly why reichard would do this
for her but he went far and beyond in
helping his sister reichardt essentially
took all of the blame for the knight of
black knives and solidified his
blasphemous ideals by feeding himself to
the god devouring serpent it's theorized
that he worked with ronnie in order to
defy the greater will as he agreed with
ronnie that no one should have to live
under their rule while he may have been
helping his sister in this process
feeding himself to the serpent is likely
a case of seeking more power and greed
his followers also follow this
blasphemous path as they also wish to
destroy the urgery and the influence of
the greater will however it seems like
his followers don't care much for
reichardt's decision to feed himself to
the serpent as he's become satisfied
gluttonous and somewhat lazy in his
efforts that were once righteous but is
now just taken over by greed it could be
a similar story to that of godric
seeking more power in order to live up
to the expectations of the family or in
reichardt's case his siblings ronnie and
radon in the hallways of volcano manor
we can tell from this interaction that
reichard is no longer himself pray to
reichardt's ambitions
though blasphemous
marked him a worthy sovereign
but they were reduced to gluttonous
depravity
once he gave himself to the serpent
whatever that thing is
it is no longer prater reichard
reichard found this power game to be
impossible on his own he gave up on the
greater will and took the road of the
blasphemous instead this could be why he
considers the warriors champions and
gods alike that he devours as family in
order to fill that hole that he is left
behind in order to seek that power
together
[Music]
radon was known as the most powerful
demigod of them all a ferocious warrior
wielding the power to control gravity
and even the stars above but this
reasoning for doing so is a wholesome
one a younger much smaller radon learned
gravity spells in the small town of
celia it's theorized that radon had some
genetic traits only known to that of the
giants as radon grew rapidly in size as
he grew older but radon had a soft spot
in his heart for his scrawny yet trusty
steed known as leonard radon learned
gravity spells in order to hover
slightly above his beloved horse so that
he would not crush him as radon grew
larger radon became a warrior not only
for the greater will but likely for his
idol godfrey godfrey's lion companion
known as swarosh became the branding for
radon's red main warriors and is a
signifier of his own golden armor radon
also commanded the stars above this
could be for many different reasons but
could have also been because he knew of
ronnie's plan and could stop her path by
stopping the movement of the stars
themselves or he could have known the
horrifying creatures that lurked above
the world and wish to protect the lands
between by holding them in their place
in the sky however when we fight radon
he is no longer in his right mind he has
been infected with scarlet rot after his
battle with melania which ended with her
releasing the full power of this disease
this rot infected not only radon but the
entirety of the continent of palid that
his red main soldiers are still trying
to ward off with fire radon was not dead
after this but he might as well have
been he could no longer command his army
or control himself general radar is
cursed ever to wander
eaten from the inside by melania's
scarlet rot his wits are long gone
now he gathers the corpses of former
friends and foes are like gorging on
them like a dog
howling at the sky
now his soldiers sing in unison to mourn
and honor their leader holding a
festival to celebrate war and the legacy
radon once had they want to give radon
what they believe he deserves an
honorable warrior's death by the hands
of powerful champions like us when we
fight him he is succumbing to the
disease that eats away inside of him
he's holding back the stars in order to
protect his home and he is also still
hovering over his beloved steed leonard
battling with him to the very end radon
is one of the demigods who if we were
fighting him at his true strength and
right frame of mind we may stand no
chance against him
the last of ratagon in ranala's children
is ronnie the witch a powerful sorceress
that was taught magical spells by the
blue snow witch known as renna when we
first find ronnie she introduces herself
as her teacher rena likely to hide her
true identity as she doesn't know
whether or not to trust us at this point
quite yet
a pleasure to meet thee tarnished
i am the witch rena
i'd heard tell of a tarnished hurting
about atop a spectral steed
and upon looking into the matter
the talk isomize is of thee we don't
know much about ronnie's true strength
before the shattering what we do know is
what she wanted to do with her power she
wanted to break free from the empyrean
flesh to no longer be influenced by the
two fingers and the greater will at the
end of her questline we can see she's
completed her task finally killing her
two fingers that was likely held up in
the sky by her brother radon this is
just the theory itself but it's likely
why there's a giant crater at the
cathedral of manicellus ronnie's two
fingers crashed down to earth after we
defeated radon we could then find the
hidden eternal city of nochron in order
to continue ronnie's quest which
ultimately ends here at the body of her
two fingers where we can start a consort
ship with ronnie and decide the fate of
the world after we become the elden lord
ronnie's power is mysterious but she is
clearly more powerful than we may even
realize initially she's mysterious
because she wishes to be and her actions
throughout the lands between like her
plot during the night of black knives
really shows us how far she's willing to
go in order to achieve what she needs
also the fact that she can just repel
and seemingly just not care when we
attack her should show us all we need to
know in regards to her power
finally we have the twin prodigies
mykola and melania they are the result
of the consort ship between queen
america and ratagon who i hope we all
know at this point are the same person
because of this i'm not sure how america
and radagon could have ever even had
children together regardless of this
confusion they did have children and
these children were born from
afflictions at birth melania harbored
the power of the rock god making her the
goddess of rot mikala was born of
eternal youth where we don't know the
extent of this affliction because we
barely even see mikala what i do know is
that melania is the blade of mykola she
reminded me and i'm sure all of you of
this many times
he's my words
i am
melania blade of mikala melania had to
harbor within this power of the rot for
her entire life the scarlet rot is
constantly trying to bloom within her
however melania knows what can happen if
the rot is freed to spread this is just
speculation on my part but melania was
likely chosen to harbor the rot god in
order to stop its spread throughout the
world mykola created the unalloyed gold
needle in order to stop the meddling of
the outer gods which the rot god is one
of we can use this needle to tame the
flame of frenzy in the dragonlord's boss
room if we wish but he also made
unalloyed gold to help his sister's
constant pain of holding back this rock
melania likely struggled throughout her
life with this affliction she found
relatability with those harbored at the
shaded castle in house mirai inside the
castle we can find elimer of the briar
gazing at a portrait of melania in my
opinion elimer was likely obsessed with
melania since they had a similar burden
to bear as we can read from the mirai
robe item description that the sons of
house mirai are all sickly born little
wonder that malai mirai would be so
beguiled by the beautiful and fierce
goddess who was born into rot they took
mikala's unalloyed gold in order to
create prosthetics that melania could
use in battle not only to increase her
strength but to also hold back the
spread of the rot she holds within
however on two different occasions
melania was forced to unleash the
scarlet rot in order to try and defeat
her opponent the first was against of
course radon she found his strength to
be too great to defeat on her own so she
decided to let go and essentially nuke
the continent of caled with the full
power of the scarlet rod after this she
was taken back to the halo tree by one
of her soldiers to rest and recover next
to mikola mikala was nowhere to be found
and we are the next person she fights
against and allows the scarlet rot to
bloom once again turning her into the
rot goddess mikola's attempts to cure
her sister of this affliction had failed
as mykla was removed from the halo tree
which is theorized to house this cure
for her unfortunately nicola's removal
from the tree halted its growth and
michael's soldiers can be seen searching
for him in a panic as he is beloved by
almost all in the lands between in
regards to mykola he is quite literally
the most mysterious character in the
game here's what we do know mykola
created the haleg tree after he realized
that the urgery could not help cure his
sister melania of her scarlet rot the
haley tree was also known as a refuge
for the albanorics and the misbegotten
as they were being degraded and
slaughtered throughout the lands between
it's also theorized through cut content
that mikala is saint trina otherwise
known as the god of slumber lance
mcdonald made an amazing video showing
us this cut content and i urge you all
to go watch his video which will be
linked in the description we also know
that mikola was well loved by his father
ratagon who gifted mikala with the rings
of light incantation which reads one of
the incantations of the golden order
fundamentalists a gift of gratitude to
the young mykola from his father radagon
and yet the young mykola abandoned
fundamentalism for it could do nothing
to treat melania's accursed rot this was
the beginning of the unalloyed gold
mikola is the number one character i
want to learn more about but
unfortunately not even moog can get any
response from this young emperian
thank you all for watching the video i
really hope you enjoyed it just another
reminder to subscribe and check out the
patreon if you want to support further
and get early access to these videos i'm
really proud of the insane growth we've
had on this channel over the past couple
of months so any support is greatly
appreciated by myself and my dog joy who
is still getting treats and belly rubs
for every new subscriber so thank you
all again enjoy the rest of your day and
i will see you all again soon take care
[Music]
you